So, now that we've seen a couple of different functions, let's talk about how to
actually use them. When we had a computer program, we saw that we would take our
function, type the name out, and then in the parentheses, where we know that the
input goes, we could type a specific number like 4 for example, like we did
before. And then because the function was already defined in the program, when
we ran this, with an actual number as the input, it would give us an answer. It
would spit out in this case a 1. We can do a similar thing with the mathematical
version of this function. Once again, in the slot where the input goes. Inside
the parenthesis right here, we can write a number. Let's pick a different one
this time just to spice things up a little bit. Maybe 5. Now the way that we use
this new input of 5, is we substitute it in to all the places where we see x in
the expression on the right hand side over here. So, in fact the first term you
see is an x, so we replace that with the 5. And then the rest of the expression
is the same. We started off with f of x equals x minus 3 and that means we know
that f of 5 is equal to 5 minus 3. We can evaluate this to see that f of 5 is
equal to 2. So 5 here is our input, and when plugged in to this function, the
function relates the input of 5 to an output, which in this case is 2. This in
fact creates a point for us. We can now plot the point 5 comma 2. This is a
point that lies on this line. Since we know that we're just replacing our
dependent variable with f of x instead of y, we graph all the values of f of x
of the function of the output just as we would y values on the vertical axis.
So, what if I have a different function instead? Maybe f of x equals x squared.
What if I want to plug in 4 as the input for this equation? What would the
function give me as the output then? Please simplify your answer as much as
possible, so that it's just a single number.